[Musique]
l'avenir
la mienne on à venir
c'est là bien que ça veut dire bien
qu'est ce que ça veut dire bien qu'ils
pensent at on dit oui bah ouais mais
voilà ça va ce que ça veut dire à
l'avenir qu'est ce que tu fais de mon
mieux qu'est ce que je vais vous lire je
crois je dois vivre moi c'est tout
[Musique]
on l'appelait autrefois le faubourg
souffrent et pas seulement parce qu'il
abritait des fabriques de l'uimm est
aujourd'hui encore derrière les façades
vierge de ces nouveaux immeubles le
xiiie arrondissement sans parfois le
souffle un parfum de mauvaise réputation
car qui est fermé mosaïque de village le
13e seger frotter à la capitale lorsque
les vieux habitants du quartier traverse
la place d'italie ils disent qu'ils vont
à paris comme les jeunes vont en bois
que samedi soir c'est à dire dans les
dancings et toujours hors du quartier
mais la rénovation urbaine brise peu à
peu ses frontières la moitié des
habitants de l'arrondissement a quitté
ou doit quitter les vieilles maisons en
attendant et pour de nombreuses années
encore de monde se bouscule briques
contre béton cité ouvrière contre hlm ou
jelen le village résiste encore devant
ces constructions qui se donne des airs
de grand ensemble 2 art de vivre
s'affrontent celui du bavardage entre
voisins sur le palier et celui de
l'ascenseur deux catégories de jeunes
aussi et nouveaux qui ne se connaissent
pas et que l'on ne connaît pas les
autres ceux qui sont nés dans le xiiième
encore pétri la tradition de la zone ce
sont tous ces jeunes que nous avons
rencontrés dans l'angle du boulevard de
la gare et de la rue du château des
rentiers un îlot qui porte le numéro 4
et des
erreurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au premier soir dans un bar du vieux
quartier nous avons connu ce que nous
ayons 116 croiser dans les rues de lille
aux 4 michel
deux bières
de cette levée alors de bière à 51
ricard le
dominique m eur dans la journée
étudiants le soir
non
michel le barman ou passé tourmenté
ramon éducateur depuis cinq ans dans ce
quartier
[Musique]
il y avait le quartier qui était
très fermé voix c'était des taudis avait
décidé il ya quelques très très fermé
kisa l'auteur où il attend parce que
dehors c'était pas comme à l'intérieur
il y avait une différence enfin c'est le
début du racisme déjà que les autres
sont pas comme nous donc il faut déjà
s'en méfier
quand on compte en a commencé à sur le
plan quand l'urbanisme quand l'organisme
a commencé à se développer les
structures intérieures sont brisés
d'elles-mêmes presse ce qu'ils ont
protesté à un moment quand on triche et
nouveaux immeubles contre la
construction
la modification du quartier pas au
départ il ya eu il ya eu un réflexe un
peu d'auto défense je pense qu'ils sont
pas très vendu tellement rendu compte de
ce qu'est ce qui est passé par contre
quand il ya eu des grandes barak par là
ils ont pensé aux éventuelles sur
bourbon onana quoi sur dit vas y avoir
des filles vont bien il va falloir se
déguiser et puis aller vers les fixes et
j'ai l'impression que les filles
restent chez elles au tour dans la rue
pour voir s'il ya des filles des confins
ne contient pas encore le lien en lien
se fera certainement demain
née dans une cité ouvrière michel
vagabonde dans le treizième depuis qu'il
a quitté ses parents il ya six ans il a
couché dans les caves les terrains
vagues et plus souvent maintenant dans
une chambre a mis une vie de hasard à
l'image du quartier
on compte les gens qui se connaissent
pas
je sais que je vois au métro nacional
por
mais à la sortie du métro vers 6h et
janry marche tous des robots
il pas vraiment leurs huit heures par
jour ils prendront soin de visage je
m'attends c'est pareil par le panel
je les vois pas le même que samedi dès
fois héros ils sortent un peu genre peu
de sourire le dimanche aussi quand il ya
du soleil
moi j'ai trop moches les gens avant j'ai
trouvé moins moche c'est marrant je suis
pas si c'est la modernisation tout ça
mais j'ai trouvé moins moche with you
l'est où il faisait quelque chose je
sais pas mais c'était pas c'était pas
des bêtes
monsanto se retirer chacun pour soi
c'est fait
puisqu'elle est jeune on changeait
vraiment
ah ouais l'on changé de mentalité
moi je crois qu'ils ont changé
qu'est ce que c'est la mentalité
c'est pas la mentalité c'est
c'est plus arriviste
ils font quelque chose c'est pour servir
à quelque chose vous consentez notre
réussite et pour centrer dans la rue
au nom quand je prends quand ils sortent
pour aller en boîte pourquoi je suis non
sentait bon c'était pour s'amuser
pendant une dispute on s'amuse on va en
boîte maintenant s'amuse on savait
cependant guad pas tu vas en boîte sur
la mettons qu'il ya 300 personnes en a
200 condamnés ont construit et j'abuse
pas
même casting même chaussée
des whiston à
50 mille balles lapeyre
ont presque la même force que l'actuel
et clark
qui parle aux gars y va bosser ivan
usines puissent achète son petit costard
sa petite paire de pompes
puis à retrouver les petits moules est
sans pareil chez lui
en boîte tu vas en boîte
tu dis tu va inviter une fille a lancé
une invite à danser et puis être regardé
puis a travaillé à toi d'en haut d'en
boire 10 ou l'étrange oralement
jean-louis ckoi gens non un costard et
costa reald et paul kennedy y
assister à la motte
à dire va chercher ton jean-raymond
après qu'il y en a eu l'idée qu'est ce
que c'est une bonne mentalité c'est un
gars qui est courageux pour parler entre
nous mais c'est un gars qui est régulier
surtout envers lui-même quand même si tu
fais une connerie du moment où tu le
sens ici tu te sens par un [ __ ]
tu étais plus jeune tout à fait des
exemples juin
ouais mais si c'était pas pareil j'ai
quand j'étais jeune j'ai suivi l'exemple
parce que j'ai pris ce qui me tombait
sous la main j'allais pas prendre un
exemple c'est mieux
comme ça
il
j'étais obligée qui par exemple
qui ou quel exemple
voici le pitch à dire
aux clichés
bah si j'avais connu arsène lupin cela a
été un exemple pour moi
[Musique]
non
parce qu'on vient de dire par jour hors
piste
[Musique]
4h 5h
travail
travail seront
suivis
et je cherche à savoir je pense comme
les gens cherchent à savoir ce que je
fais dans un café où il chez moi je
cherche à savoir ce qu'ils font à 12
communes pas trouvé un plaisir à lui j
aime les plaisirs qui cherchent une
usine c'est autre chose de la part de
l'argent ça plaisir c'est pareil
quand tu pourrais encore hésiter
longtemps d'être un prolo
je serais sûrement pas pour le poste par
get
crois pas une seconde je pourrait
toutefois toucher pas moins que la
charge
bayard tout ce que tu vois je vois mes
projets six gymnases et parce que je
m'emmerde si je bats je m'emmerde
jeu pendant logement je l'avoué os et
puis c'est tout
si si j'avais je sais pas si j'avais une
culture si j'avais appris pour un métier
c'est négatif le métier apprendre un
métier travailler en usine trois ans
d'apprentissage est plus fort un nom
n'est pas quelque chose qui me plaît si
mes parents ma part ma bd si les gens
m'avaient des s'il m'avait pas mis des
bâtons dans les roues
j'aurais peut-être fait quelque chose
qui me plaisait
tu accuses qui jacques husky
la société
tu me regardes des gens qui m'écoutent
gens qui me pose des questions tout le
monde
presque l'impression quand tu dis quand
tu dis prolos c'est presque une insulte
bien sûr
pas j'espère qu'ils prennent pour un
adulte j'espère qu'ils vont m'en vouloir
j'ai pas ils sont vachement
jeu trop facile les prolos quoi
voici aussi je peux le faire je bossais
joaillier frères matip pas à mes petits
enfants puis joyal est ma télé je
trouvais at il
n'en restera pas là
quitte à choisir je préfère le vol que
je ne veux faire exploiter
vivent de mendicité ça ne dit rien
dit que le treizième à dresde imputation
way pour les gens
mais pour les jeunes qui arrivent de la
mauvaise réputation
c'était égal ou pas que tu veux mais je
m'en veux mais ça m'empêche d'aller vers
eux c'est tout je reste avec ce qu'ils
pensent de moi c'est tout
sinon tir est bien en dessous je serai
leur expliquer je pense qu importe quoi
pourquoi on est comme ça pourquoi
pourquoi les fourneaux pour y travailler
quoi on s'emmerde
pourquoi on a les cheveux longs
aussitôt qu'on sera là et puis tu vois
une autre prime
c'est pas la peine d'essayer de discuter
[Musique]
il ya si tu veux il ya l'ambiance
pendant mais
bon c'était c'était pas pareil paraguay
relâchement qui choque
c'est à dire que redouté entre copains
[Musique]
il est apparu 15,9 qui descendait y
avait 50 de son deuil
137 boulevard de l'hôpital qui
descendait j'avais 24 derrière
la valeur étant donné que ça a changé de
pied tous là
c'est plus du tout pareil
de l'autre côté de la rue les immeubles
neufs planté là depuis parfois sept ans
nous avons réuni une dizaine de jeunes
habitants la travailleurs lycéens et
étudiants la plupart ne se connaissaient
pas avant la réunion pourtant certains
habitaient depuis plusieurs années la
même cage d'escalier quels sont vos
contacts avec les les jeunes du quartier
mais ceux qui y habitaient là déjà avant
par exemple des cités ouvrières
donc un avocat
ans trouve enfin aucun contact parce que
s'ils cherchent pas voir des contacts
avec eux je pense si on essayait d'aller
les voir de s'approcher un peu plus
certaines bâtisses m'enfin la plupart du
temps on passera à côté à notre charge
palais les bois entendu des gens dire va
pas jouer avec ceux d'en face et qu'elle
se trouve même à whitehall bâtiment
tourner la péninsule de la maison d'en
face
rochette ne renvoie pas que j'étais sans
partage avec eux mais les parents que
six interdite on a déjà enfin il se
demande pense qu'ils sont différentes de
vie puisque mais interdit de jouer avec
le croyez vraiment ce sont les parents
qui font la différence ou est-ce que
certains d'entre vous la fois aussi
soit voyons là certains d'entre nous qui
l' aquila fond pourquoi pas ce que je
dis ce sont des délinquants ne sont pas
comme moi le réformer les met de côté je
veux pas avoir affaire à eux c'est vrai
quelqu'un pense à ballon
parce qu'il faut quand même pas
généraliser dire travailler c'est des
faits raconte parce que il ya des
limites on va pas et trouve sur
délégation et les voix on est dégoûtés
il faut qu'on le voir il faut qu'on se
parle pour qu'on discute bon ils ont
leur motivation on a les nôtres on a vu
les niveaux de vie qui sont pour la
plupart différents les études qui sont
différentes vous n'êtes pas cohabiter un
étudiant
et un peas vous veillez eux
ils ont par exemple les mêmes loisirs
j'essaie niveau de vie bascule une façon
revenir vers nous pour établir des
quotas al'inverse
dans quelques années vous aurez des
enfants est ce que ce qu'ils joueront
avec ceux des cités ouvrières
[Musique]
si je dois répondre personnellement
j'espère que le poil
je ne suis pas
ça m'est difficile de répondre pour
beaucoup de raisons mais j'aimerais pas
pour cette question tout le monde tout
le monde est comme ça finalement se dit
intel qui devra pas fréquenter un tel
parce que son père est ce si vous sa
mére cela est d'ailleurs des préjugés
parfois stupide s'il s'agit d'aller
traîner entre entre 5 et 8 heures dans
la rue rien faire je trouve pas ça très
très utile et je pense qu'on peut vous
trouver mieux que ça je m'arrangerai
pour qu'il soit autrement mais j'ai pas
ce que j'ai léger aucun droit et à
empêcher des enfants des choisir leur
leurs amis au fond n'est-ce pas qu'un
que tous finalement de presse
vous avez peur des citoyens
[Musique]
banane en tout cas d'hésitante je serai
je crois que ce n'est pas une peur
vraiment enfin c'est qu'on a eu c'est
une crainte de se laisser entraîner et
vous avez plus ou moins de raisons de
vous ennuyer finalement rien n'est fait
puis ce n'est pas s'ennuyer
on disait que l'animation du quartier
ici était pratiquement inexistant en
juillet que les jeunes qui se trouvent
dans les militants les habitations
envoyée je pense qu'au fond autant
s'ennuyer que par exemple le dimanche
c'est pas parce que l'on est là on a un
centre de loisirs il faut sortir du
troisième pour aller s'amuser alors que
si l'on pouvait s'amuser dans le
troisième on restera là et rien n'est
fait pour cela et aussi c'est la même
chose c'est pas parce que l'on n'est pas
devant chez nous sur nos maux de tête on
ne s'ennuie pas
on peut très bien s'ennuyer entre quatre
murs évidemment ça ne se voit pas
les mêmes raisons s'ennuyer et presque
les mêmes raisons de s'ignorer le pense
dominique et monique dans leur cité
ouvrière
pour moi je le comprends ils sont pas
différents de moi et c'est eux qui se
croisent différents lots sont pareils
ils croient supérieurs chez pourquoi
y'a garde de samedi soir si vous leur
part leurs fenêtres et puis ils disent à
l'eau à la ville de relogement là il est
beau on regarde les habitera tonnes
maisons en briques ce que ça signifie
que par exemple y aura moins de
délinquants parmi ces jeunes là
qui seront vraiment
[Musique]
maintenant les appellera plus les
délinquants je crois pas
en face on les appelle rapide et rien
qu'en pense qu'ils ont peut-être des
démons des raisons autres que la venue à
l'arrêt comme les plus jeunes le volet
de camping
ils ont droit d'autres non oui on change
ça paraît
toute façon qui soit you
enfants de georges bizet ou enfants de
dubaï et il sait pas à ces paroles et de
la coi
pour moi c'est la société qui les fait
comme ça
tu as toujours pensé ça sur la société
sur balles alors quand je suis sorti de
l'école pro tellement à penser à vue qui
nous apprennent pas un point c'est
tellement à l'école ils nous disent bon
c'est comme ça on n'a qu'à dire non
c'est pas comme ça où vous savez rien ou
des john se dévouent de près
l'expérience
c'est un
registre after et puis un garde et puis
quand on regarde on voit qu'il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas vous avez
l'impression de ne pas exister
maintenant dans trois ans bah moi je
crois que j'existe de taupont pensant
j'existe quand même je suis là j'existe
pour rjh existe pas c'est une question à
discuter
[Applaudissements]
une pichenette sur une petite voiture
les trottoirs de l'îlot 4 voilà le
véritable terrain de jeu des gosses du
quartier ils habitent les cités
ouvrières ou les immeubles neufs la rue
et quelques ruines riche de trouvailles
et de promesses la rue mais jamais le
pelouse puisque des messieurs en
imperméable sont chargés de veiller à ce
que l'on respecte bien le gazon
on
est tous dans les hlm sont en
face à ces voix là il est bien on
travaille une pelouse du royal ce que
vous avez fait de plus
intelligent du ballon c'est pas con
niveau mauvais mais enfin c'est pas le
lieu ni l'endroit pour jouer au ballon
pourquoi moi c'est interdit parce que
c'est vous de prière du ballon on veut
les entraîner un pur à l'effort de
choisy le roi pourquoi risquer des
écoles bientôt
aller à la poterne des peupliers vient
de leur faire c'est interdit de rendre
et c'est pas ici vous aurez le droit non
plus
mais bon loisirs c'est pas tellement la
route on sait surtout c'est surtout rien
et la rue des lacs pour
éventuellement se retrouver mais c'est
pas tellement de loisirs
y à rien alors automatiquement on se
retrouve en bas de chez soi pour voir
d'autres pour éventuellement voir ce que
l'on peut faire ensemble aller au cinéma
les danses et à les faire n'importe quoi
mais
dans la rue de la rue n'a pu là
mon rôle qu'elle avait avancé certains
sont effectivement il ya des petits
squares au milieu de ces grandes
constructions nouvelles on voit les
petits squares c'est quoi correspondent
pas à grand chose les jeunes préfèrent
de loi allait sur les terres aval taper
dans un ballon dans les terrains vagues
taper dans un ballon sport hasard quoi
quand on trouve 10 20 30 50 jeunes dans
un terreau à valdes en tapant dans un
ballon ou même dans des boîtes de
conserve
et qu'à côté on voit super petit parc
avec où tout est prévu et complètement
désert certainement par hasard lorsque
terrain vague en général il ya des
pierres il ya encore à côté naturel
ont construit des terrains vagues ça va
rien dire toute façon mais faire quelque
chose où les enfants du droit de
demander aux enfants ce qu'ils
voudraient c'est encore ça c'est encore
une fois je vais pas l'adulte et je vais
dire il faudrait faire ceci et cela qui
m'a dit hier que ce qui était important
pour toi c'est c'est que les gosses dont
tu t'occupes soient bien dans leurs
frais je redis
oui enfin je crois que c'est le principe
du terrain ben quoi on peut prévoir
l'état de chose ça ne veut pas dire que
ça corresponde à et dansez dansez grande
baraque dans ces hlm tout ça
effectivement c'est très pratique
matériellement on vit mieux mais
loeb là dedans est un peu paumé l'homme
est encore plus l'enfant est beaucoup
plus perdu c'est pas très bien il en est
sur pas toujours très bien dans leur
peau alors
quand quand je peux
aider à khost à être bien dans sa peau
je crois que c'est déjà énorme
mieux vaut
[Applaudissements]
aller les façons je voulais pardon je
voulais passer
à
tout d'abord aller au bout ouais on est
[Applaudissements]
amoureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'équipe de football que dirigera
man l'éducateur rené ne ressemble plus
tout à fait aux autres mariés depuis
trois mois il a quitté le xiiie
arrondissement
il s'est rangé comme le disent les
autres c'est à dire qu'ils travaillent
régulièrement dans une entreprise de
transport et qu'il veut à tout prix
oublier le passé
pour cartes ont tous une fois par
semaine dans le xiiie arrondissement ces
projets coûtent brûle et d'être pas ou
n'est bon qu'à parole manon novembre et
le sport j'ai toujours aimé le sport
je me projette encore maintenant même
que chez marié tu crois vraiment que
c'est pas le football que tes
entraîneurs ont pour les deux pour voir
les copains
on se trompe
on se trouve bien dans votre café
j'établis un village habité pendant plus
de 18 ans dans ce quartier
d'annoncer j'habite je connais personne
pages fait un peu dépaysé quoi est-ce
que tu avais peur du xiiie
arrondissement
j'ai eu peur avril dernier moment
j'ai pas du tout quand l'environnement
des fréquentations surtout
peur d'être eux mêmes
un peu
une cravate et une cravate avant j'en
mettais pas avant j'étais toujours
débraillé à lauzon
tout crasseux
c'est important la cravate
oui c'est important je crois que c'est
important
on juge quelqu'un part je crois que
maintenant juste quelqu'un oserait cité
moderne jusqu'à 15 et bien habillé
les mariages pour tracer une sorte de
réussite sociale
oui je crois que c'est une réussite
sociale
un conte se marie on pense à beaucoup de
choses
c'était facile difficile
ça n'est encore un peu difficile j'ai dû
m'habituer une mariée mais pour moi
c'est pas tout à fait noir mais presque
là encore
c'est facile de se faire adopter par une
famille cet étonnant ça a été dur parce
que j'étais
j'avais déjà parlé je parlais encore
beaucoup à faire et laisser ma femme et
par ont été choqués j'avais à dire
bruges par les labels verts comme si je
parlais
elle apporte un kiwi
non ça s'est arrangé je me suis fait la
lettre
sont très gentilles
ton avis pourquoi tu es maintenant si
différente de ce qui était en jeu comme
ça ma femme tu as qui m'a beaucoup
changé
quand je parle à lille c'est pas comme
ça qu'on dit c'est comme si une bombe je
m'en rappellerai
ici un copain demander quelque chose
elle l'était
ça dépend ça dépend quel
moi je crois je le ferai
c'est vos problèmes de cette tournée
c'est très bien il est relativement aisé
quand j'étais dans le besoin
je sais ma femme c'est
pour ma part
comment tu les justes et un siècle pas
du xiiie qui continuent à vivre la
victime en est très proche on peut pas
juger ce chacun reste son mode de vie
moi je sais je vous le changez vous
échangez y en a qui veulent pas changer
là qui semble bien avant impôts moi je
me sentais pas bien dans ma peau je
voulais changer de peau
jamais eu de regret s'il se met très
vite j'ai choisi en amenant je pendrai
non je suis très bien
une belle farce études et moi
je suis tranquille j'ai tout vu ce que
je veux
j'ai une femme sur le kin comprends
c'est ça le plus important
c'est lé moment que tu te dis on me pour
celui là c'est gagné c'est réussi ou est
ce que le doute persiste en permanence
gagné
dallier par rapport à quoi quand je vois
un type e enfin je sais pas
encore faudrait-il qu'il y ait des
normes
gagner ça veut dire qu'il est dans le
bien et qu'il est dans le mal surtout
par rapport à lui même ou quoi quand on
lui a trouvé une issue dont bien quand
il est bien dans sa peau il a une vie
sociale comme tout le monde on prend le
cas on obtient des dégâts qui soit
disant
on voit envoyer très mal leur
possibilité de s'insérer dans la
collectivité ont trouvé une charmante de
petit matin et puis l'aiment et puis
tout est résolu et alors là tous les
tous les cours de morale sont en deçà de
cette petite dame enfin si ces frais
qu'on voit si tu es moi je cherche à
imaginer comment comment tu peux
répondre à ces gaz tu peux leur parler
je peux où je ne peux pas c'est ça le
problème c'est que des fois je ne peux
pas bon bien le mieux et je leur dise
bon bah tu me pose une question et vous
une bulle où il ya une demande des
jeunes peut pas répondre à ta demande
c'est aussi éducatif que de répondre
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs et de répondre
je pense que enfin on avait parlé
surtout au niveau de contact humain où
il ya un bonhomme via notre bonhomme ont
fait confiance on pense que ce bonhomme
est un critère entre guillemets encore
faut-il définir secrétaire et on vient
lui poser une question qui n'est pas
capable il faut qu'ils soient élèves
pourront pas tricher vous pouvez rumba
je sais pas et toi qu'est ce que tu en
penses
et bien souvent quand on lui a posé une
question on a en partie la réponse
je crois que c'est assez vrai ça
mange pas je pense à un garçon qui
depuis un bon moment
david puech ses parents qu'il a
maintenant une vingtaine d'années ça
fait un moment
et
ce qu'il cherche justement c'est être
bien dans sa peau il fait des conneries
et c'est vrai mais il sait à peu près
jusqu'où il peut aller jusqu'à
doit s'arrêter quand on attitude alors
face à son succès si vous avez des
repères c'est de l'aider c'est de
l'aider à
même des fois se casser la gueule entre
en compte king qui n'est pas trop de
blessures qui n'est pas trop de marques
mais s'il faut qu'il se casse la gueule
il cassera la gueule
t'as jamais donner conseils romain non
m'a fait voir ce qui existait
je crois que c'est tout je peux pas dire
qu'il va être conseiller tireur fait pas
ça c'est ainsi qu'on m'a dit ci fais pas
ça parce que tu es perdre on
m'a dit moi je rattrape lâche pas pour
ça parce que tu es perdant
mais on peut pas dire c'est pas le temps
qui va raconter des bobards la bonne
moralité fait pour ça parce que ceci
parce que ceux-là n'ont pas dit si tu
fais ça tu es perdant maintenant si tu
fais justement dans les doigts c'est
tout
[Musique]
je dis quelquefois
finalement est ce que je fais mon métier
pour faire mon métier par la bonne
conscience et pas tellement ça c'est
pourri a également certainement pour
alain
[Musique]
on a conscience qu'il est surtout par la
bonne conscience des jeunes c'est
surtout la pression est pensé pour ou
encore moi je pense que j'ai engagée
dans une action tout en doute la rigueur
et le chargeur de réflexion mais je le
dis c'est pas si mal je pense ou 7 juin
g ses proches devient dès l'année de
conscience de georges qui constatent
qu'ils continuent
[Musique]